this chinese indonesian guy was a
politician
no he was the guy he was the middle man
so what he realized was
um because i was like okay cool we have
this coal what do we do with it he's
like oh we just sell it immediately as
soon as we sign the paper we have the
call
we sell it to exxon and i'm like oh okay
so how does that work he's like well
i bought all this coal for two million
and then we like i bought all the coal
for two million
and then we sell it in blocks for 20
million each
i'm like well that's like 400 500
million how are we we're turning 2
million into 500 million
and he's like yeah i'm like well what
that's amazing like
why didn't exxon why don't they just go
in directly by this
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's
travel never looking back i just got
vaccinated
um uh that's pretty cool i got a new toy
you want to see
oh nice sam's holding up a gun
[Laughter]
i was uh just i just drove by a a bass
pro shop
and i walked in and i was like i was
just walking around just to look at like
beef jerky or something
and i just saw it and i've never
even remotely owned anything like that
and i was like hey those are cool
can i buy one get certified or like do a
background check or something you just
walk into a bass pro shop and buy a gun
um
well yeah i mean i just walked up to the
counter and i go oh those are hand guns
those are neat what's the deal like how
do you buy one of those and they go well
just give us your driver's license and
we'll run a background check and you can
walk out in five minutes and i go
huh sick i'll take that one you just
held it away
today like you didn't hold the gun part
you held it with two fingers and like
it was pointed sideways
yeah i still have to learn how to use it
i don't even have ammo for it and i have
like a lock on it i'm like
pretty paranoid i got to figure out how
to use the damn thing
um very texas oh we have something we
have well
i'm a i'm a texas resident resident now
we have something cool happening on
wednesday
yeah we are gonna interview jake paul
which might be in terms of just like
famous people might be the most famous
person we've ever interviewed
probably the most famous person i've
ever met um i met the pope once
um i met bill i met bill clinton when he
was in office all right you peaked so
but jake jake i did that both of those
when i was uh
like eight years old so jake paul is
like number three but when you say you
james didn't
pause what does that mean you saw the
pope you you shake hands with the pope
what is what does it take to meet the
pope
uh shake hands that said hi in a busy
crowd
not oh that's pretty good all right you
shook hands let's see who is the most
or did we like more like a high five it
was more like a high five
bill clinton bill clinton uh i shook
his hand and like said hey uh what's
your what's your real first name and he
goes william i go hey
why do you have white hair he goes
because i'm old and that was
so i met him and he asked my name so i
actually i actually met bill clinton you
really
shot your shot with bill clinton well i
was
like six years what year was that where
you already 92 whatever it was i was
like
going on uh foreign pre yeah pre back
when he was
still young bill all right um that's
pretty good i met
uh the closest thing i ever got to that
probably was
well i have this really long orlando
bloom story that's very funny but i'm
not gonna tell it
uh but it's like if you're my friend
you've heard me tell the story 10 times
because it's just a go-to it's just a
winner
of a story uh you know the stories that
you just like you just have in the bank
if you ever need to be like you know the
life of the party impress someone
um but then i also you know the you know
the duke uh duke andrew or something
like that i forget his name is
duke andrew i think wow i'll learn how
you say his name i know the name is he
the guy did he get in trouble with
jeffrey upside yeah he just got in
trouble
uh for that or maybe for other things i
don't know something happened that's not
great for him
but he was doing a tour of silicon
valley and so we got word that oh the
duke is coming to
our office uh prince andrew duke of york
yeah that's right
uh he was the duke of york so i heard
got word oh in the morning the duke of
york is coming to the office today can
you give a presentation i didn't know
what the duke of york was
um still don't really know what the duke
of york is he's just like not in the
prince lineage but whatever
so anyways he first a full security
detail comes
sweeps the whole office you know the
morning just to make sure
they get the whole layout they know
where the entrances are they know where
the exits are
and uh they're like okay this place is
secure for the duke
and he shows up at 4 p.m and i've got
this like presentation i've been working
on i threw my whole day away
and i just started working on this
presentation for the duke and um
explaining what we do and why it's so
great i'm like i gave my all
and the presentation you've been to our
office our office has like couches not
like kind of chairs
it's a very comfortable couches so he
sits down on one of our couches
and is just flanked by security guards
and i fire up the first slide on the big
projector
and i start talking and i see that he's
asleep he is uh
passed out by the for before the first
light even starts he has no
he's fallen asleep in his chair and now
i don't know what to do because
i'm giving this presentation to this one
guy who's asleep it's all my employees
who know what the heck we do
they don't need this presentation they
all see that he's asleep
i see that he's asleep the security
guards are kind of like not saying
anything they're not doing anything
and so i give the presentation to the
sleeping duke of york for the first 20
minutes
oh my god how crazy i i was so lame i
just that's actually really cringe
well i'll i'll finish the story with one
thing because it's kind of relevant to
what we do
so at the end because we were in idea
lab
and like this podcast about
brainstorming business ideas and talking
about
shooting the [__] about business ideas
so we i basically paused at the end and
i was like okay i could keep going but
like
it would be more fun if you actually
joined us in doing what we do and
kind of brainstorm some business ideas
and so we asked him a bunch of questions
we're like do you guys
like what apps do you guys use and he
was like we don't have phones
like what he's like he's like we don't
get to use our like personal cell phones
i guess at that time i didn't know
exactly what he's saying but there's
some
limitation where they don't have they
don't just have like iphones with
normal apps and they can do whatever
they want it's like very like
pre-installed use this phone use what it
has
and like if you want more go to it and
they'll they'll help you or something
like that
and then i go what business ideas you
have he goes
there needs to be a fact checker so
politicians can't lie
i was like what he's like we need to
hold politicians to
to what they say there's so many
politicians that just lie and we need
them to
and everything should be on the right
everything should be like on the record
it'd be fact checked at all times it
should be public if you're lying
that was his idea number one and then he
had something else i was like about like
i don't know like digitizing
paperwork or something like that and i
was like all right thanks prince so
there's actually wait i could riff on
that there's this thing called politico
politica uh what is it uh i actually
don't know how you pronounce this
oh god everyone makes fun of me for not
politico no uh
polita
have you ever heard of that no um
so what it does is it looks at
uh like when there's a big um
uh big election they analyze all the
major speeches uh done by some by
someone so
in the case of trump or uh biden when
they were doing their debates
they would they have a meter that is
says
true mostly true half true false
i've seen this pants on fire and they
actually check all the stuff they say
and they say this is or is that true
here's why
and it's kind of cool uh uh politifact i
guess it's called it's by the
way i like that it goes to panto fire
that's a nice thing that's pretty cool
um i like that
uh so your your boy was on to something
not a great business but it
it does there is something that does
this right um
um okay wait one more thing you said uh
we got on this tangent because you said
jake paul is coming on wednesday
so um why is jake paul coming on and
what are we gonna do about it so
jake paul okay so uh i am basically
copying sean and i started investing in
some companies
and jeffrey wu is a friend of mine i
think he's a friend of yours too
uh yeah i'm mildly close friends with
him
and he saw that i was investing and i
saw that he was investing
and he goes and we were just shooting
the [__] i go what are you doing and he
said what are you doing we exchanged
ideas he goes hey you just want to do a
phone call i'll bring on my partner jake
and i was like oh are you partnering
with jake paul he goes yeah yeah i'll
bring him on
and uh i go all right sounds good so we
just do a zoom
and i'm sitting there with jeffrey and
or jeff
and uh jake and jake's like
hey what's your cell let's just have a
text chat like a group
uh thread and uh by the way uh i love my
first million and i know the hustle like
can i come on
the podcast or or i was like yeah sounds
good
so here we are it's kind of weird
but kind of funny that's pretty legit uh
i also want to know from him
well i'm going to ask him but like jeff
is like a tech
founder sold the company uh started like
a
company backed by andreessen horowitz
it's like a keto company
and um and then somehow
somehow like partners with jake paul i
don't even know how they became friends
it's like how did this asian dude from
the tech world
become like good enough friends with
jake paul where they'll start a business
together like do you know that
no i don't i know that jeff moved miami
and jeff's like a manly man like jeff's
into guns and
fighting and big muscles and whatever
men are supposed to be into and like
jake i i
assume is also into that stuff so they
they must have met and jeff's real real
smart and savvy and i have a feeling
that it's a good stick which is like
jake's the famous one gets access
and jack is uh jeff is the straight man
who uh
you know makes make sure the uh knows
how to do it yeah and
that's historically a great partnership
it's actually there's this guy named
brian lee who does this and he's
partnered with uh
shapiro i forget shapiro's first name
but shapiro
was the lawyer for uh oj oj simpson
and they started legal zoom together and
he and shapiro was like the celebrity
and then he did it with uh kim
kardashian and they started shoedazzled
together wait weren't car what was it
kardashian's dad
uh kardashian's dad was the lawyer uh
well oj had like eight lawyers
robert shapiro is his name oj had like
eight lawyers so it was like kardashian
it was uh johnny cochran
it was uh uh uh whatever yadda yadda and
was was he the one who also partnered
with jessica alba for the honest
yeah so this guy named brian lee uh i
guess he's korean he's a
korean-american um and i guess lee's
korean i think
and uh he partnered with shapiro for
legal zoom
and shapiro was supposed to be like the
faith and the famous person turns out
shapiro
i mean he's a really successful he's a
savvy business guy so shapira goes
let's do this with some more celebrities
so they partner with kim kardashian and
they do shoe dazzle which raises a bunch
of money but i think kind of flamed out
uh but then they do it with one other
company and then eventually they do it
with jessica alba
and honesco on his company and it's the
same thing jessica alba was supposed to
be like shapiro kind of like the face
the famous person turns out she's pretty
savvy apparently
uh and good at uh you know whatever
whatever
it is she's good at i guess running a
business i don't know what her role is
but she's great
and that's what he does uh and so
partnering with celebrities can actually
work out quite well this company is a
that's a big company that's like a
that's like a big that's like a billion
dollar company i think
uh the honest code i think i think what
do we want to talk about today i got a
bunch of
random random topics uh do you want me
to start did you have one you wanted to
start well i actually
was researching a fair bit of your
things um because i found them to be
a little bit interesting do you want to
talk about turned yellow is that
interest or
how about you lead i'll let you lead
everything and i'll follow but i
researched all your stuff
okay we can talk about turned yellow so
we'll start there um
this is a cool business so this is in a
category
that uh our friend ryan beagleman said
this word
he was the first one i ever heard say
this i don't know if he started it or he
picked it up somewhere
but it's the term drop servicing so
people have heard of drop shipping which
is basically like
you market on facebook or wherever else
you
sell a product to a customer but it's a
product that you don't hold in inventory
you as soon as you get the order from a
customer you place an order with your
manufacturer the manufacturer ships it
directly to the person so
it's a way to do ecommerce without
having to buy and hold inventory
because you're just directly shipping to
customers straight from the factory
and typically kind of like lower margin
but it's a great way to get started if
you don't have any money in e-commerce
that's kind of like the idea
turned yellow is actually one of jack
smith's
uh favorite things jack might be an
investor but i
uh i know he's a huge customer of turned
yellow
right so what turned yellow does is
similar it's a drop servicing company so
instead of shipping your physical
product
they do a service for you kind of on
demand so turned yellow or
actually a friend of ours um i don't
know if you know the guy alex uh who's
behind it but
uh he bought the company recently and uh
i won't share any like
the numbers or anything like that but uh
alec too really
uh volor volodarsky or something like
that volo
is how you start the spelling of his
last name um
you can find him on twitter he's at
volod dark or something like that and he
also started this like
90s theme kind of like uh party or
parade or thing that used to happen like
90s jam fest or something like that was
just all nostalgia
which i thought was cool that's why i
first reached out to him and then i
found out that our
our mutual friends xavier and sieva
helped you know invested in him when he
bought turned yellow
oh so sorry it wasn't jack it was sieva
i'm i'm an investor in cf is fun that's
how i heard about this
yes okay exactly so what turned yellow
does
is they basically it's a great gift so
you can
submit a picture of your family or your
friend and they'll send you a drawing
uh like an illustration of that same
photo or that same person
turned into what looks like kind of like
a simpsons character like turned yellow
like you know all the sims characters
are yellow
so they make they cartoonize any picture
for you so it's like you
you went and got this custom made for
your friend so it's this great gift
and um simple simple business they
basically on one side they have a whole
bunch of artists
who can crank out these like
illustrations in this one art style
and on the other side they just
advertise on facebook or whatever and
their their number one advertisement is
this like
uh picture of howie mandel holding up
his turned yellow where he got turned
yellow and that
probably millions of dollars there's so
many replicas so if you
keep your ads on and type in turned
yellow so there's turn yellow.com which
is i guess i
i think the original then there's
simpson simpson
phi me then there's art of yellow and
they are all complete total ripoffs the
exact same website practically
and uh that's kind of interesting i
would have thought
this would would have you would have had
to have had some type of licensing or
blessing from citizens i think it
operates in a slightly gray area because
they don't say anything about the
simpsons but the art style does
evoke that idea that look and i think
that's part of why people are buying it
for sure it's one hundred percent the
simpsons i mean they're sitting in front
of the camera he's my friend so i'm
trying i'm trying to say it a little bit
softly here so
but anyways the cool thing what they
were doing was they bought the company
the company was doing well
i had all these competitors because
everybody was kind of doing the same
uh everybody was still trying to clone
them um and then they brought on this
badass licensing guy who has been like
in the licensing business for decades
and the idea is that he was going to go
and actually talk to all the different
ip holders of
uh simpsons and futurama and harry
potter
and any other brand and basically say
hey we would love to cut a licensing
deal with you so that we can do this
and do it like totally above board you
make some money from this we
we lose a little bit of money but we can
kind of like knock out all these
competitors who are
doing this and they don't want to work
in the aboveboard they all want to be
under the table here
and so that was the business plan and um
i don't know exactly how it's going now
but
i thought this was really cool it's a
cool business that does
uh you know very good revenue and
there's a whole bunch
that are like this and right now what
people do is they just do this for every
popular
theme so it's like you can do one like a
lot of people like rick and morty that's
like a cult phenomenon now
so people are doing this with the rick
and morty art style and then people are
doing this with another art style
and this reminds me of what our friend
uh silly did where he got the rights to
family guy
and made the family guy mobile game and
he made he made a version of candy crush
that was themed
family guy so he took a proven game
candy crush that's like super addictive
amazing at monetizing and he just
skinned it with the family guy branding
and got family guy to help promote it
and family guy got millions of dollars
in revenue from the success of this game
and then eventually
the same thing with harry potter yeah he
did the same thing with tons of stuff
but
how do you think you even like i
wouldn't even know the first thing
what do you do do you find someone uh
who happens to know someone who knows
someone and they introduce you to
someone
at fox i mean like i don't even know
that seems really hard to to make happen
yeah well i think that's why they
brought on a guy who's done decades of
licensing because he has the
connections already he maybe worked with
these same brands to do a different
licensing deal maybe putting
faces on t-shirts for bud light or
whatever right like
uh so i think that's one thing is like
there is a network aspect to it where
you can get your foot in the door
but i don't know did you ever listen to
the first episode of this podcast with
suli where he explained how he got the
family guy rights no
i mean insane story yeah i listened to
the episode but that was
uh two years ago now happened yeah
basically he
was like all right uh first why did he
need this
they were just making normal mobile
games but distribution costs kept going
up and up and up because facebook was
getting more and more expensive
to advertise on because all the game
developers were all competing as each
other bidding the prices up
so he's like [__] we need a way to stand
out we need a way to acquire users
without paying for as much in ads we
need a more efficient way to acquire
users
so he had seen that the simpsons did a
mobile game with ea
and they made like simpsons like the
quest you know i don't know what it's
called like
some simpsons game with ea he's like oh
that's genius that's what we need to do
and this is before the kim kardashian
mobile game and before
others started copying this playbook so
he's like okay what's the next franchise
that we can get
family guy so family guy is also owned
by i think fox yeah and
so they have they have simpsons and they
have family guys they go to they they
get in touch with they you know google
around they get in touch with the person
to
who who's in charge of the stuff and
they're like yeah like okay i don't know
i've never heard of your startup
but um we're gonna probably just go with
ea i mean we just did the simpsons with
them it was pretty successful like
ea is like a big name trustworthy you
don't get fired for going with ea
i might get fired if i go with you guys
so they're like okay you know fair
enough but they didn't give up and so
what he said was every he had decided
like the company was screwed if they
didn't find like pull a rabbit out of a
hat
so he just put all his chips into this
one strategy and was like okay
every morning when we come into the
office we just have a whiteboard the
whiteboard says how do we go get the
family guy rights
i was like what can we do and uh they
would just come up with some ideas and
then they would try it that day and then
they would like fail and they would come
back again the next day and like the
next day and then eventually
his number two it was only him and two
other people who knew about this plan in
a company of like
50 60 people i think and so the number
two guy was like dude we've exhausted
we've
we tried this we tried this we you know
blah blah blah and so
um eventually mark andreessen was on
their board he was their investor so
they had asked mark andreessen hey do
you you're super well connected do you
know
know the guy he said yeah i'll make a
phone call so he makes a phone call
they get the meeting but the meeting
again is like i don't know guys
so he says all right how do we pull this
off he goes first we're going to
economically make this like a ridiculous
deal for them
so like we're gonna offer them this
ludicrous upfront guarantee of x
millions of dollars of
you just get that money from day one uh
number two you're gonna get this like
awesome fat royalty on the back end uh
if this game is successful
and um so that was kind of lucrative and
they were like okay we're into that and
by the way he didn't have the money to
make like he didn't have the money to
give them yeah
promised it and was like i'll go raise
the money if they say yes
was his plan and um and then the last
thing was they found out that the guy
the main guy who's the decision maker
his like mentor or was like
a family friend of marc andreessen or
something like that and so he's like oh
talk to the mentor guy so they talk to
the mentor the mentor is like
okay guys i hear what you're saying i
like your spunk like um
i'll i'll help you out and they put them
on the board of their company
they're like dude we'll give you shares
we'll put you on the board and he was
like guys
don't need it it's okay and he put in
the word and basically that
that got the guy to like lean their way
of like yeah give these guys a chance
they're legit
don't worry about like that they're not
a big household brand
in fact these guys will go all out for
you it's life or death for them and
that's what you want in your partner
and so that's how they ended up getting
the pitch to work and got the rights to
family guy and saved the company do you
ever think
at least i i mean i think of this and do
you um
when i think of stories like this i
think to myself like
why wouldn't you just go to this person
with the job
and just be like and just say all the
obvious
which is dude you don't want to get
fired you also hate your job
uh i'll give you a hundred thousand
dollars personally how why are you 100
grand
can you please just like like what's
stopping just like
total cronyism i mean i guess not what's
stopping it maybe i should rephrase this
it's pretty mind-boggling that that's
not more like
there's not more of that so okay so
let's let's answer both what's stopping
it well
usually the person you want to bribe is
in a pretty high up position so they're
doing well already maybe hard up for
money maybe how much do you think the
person makes a year who's like in charge
of licensing for a family guy yeah i bet
you not i bet that guys
i bet you that guy's easily pulling in
300 400 000 okay
so that's not stupid money but that's
good money
good money right so he's not like you
know he's not desperate let's put it
that way second thing
uh you know in a big company i don't
know if you've had yours yet now that
you got acquired but
there is like a whole like anti-bribery
training you have to do they really put
it in your head like hey look
even just like taking any gift over 50
tickets to a game you know a dinner you
need to report it it could be bribery
blah blah so you get it it gets put in
your head and you start to think okay
do i want to risk it all because if i
actually got caught doing this
i would basically not be able to have a
career anymore so you kind of have to
pay me so much
that i'm i'm willing to risk the odds of
me getting completely
blacklisted from my profession where
i've worked so hard to become a vp after
30 years and i'm not saying
that's like i'm not saying by the way
i'm not even remotely implying that i'm
into this
i'm just saying i'm actually of course
you're saying some other guy
might be into this what i'm saying is
i'm surprised that this doesn't
i'm surprised it doesn't happen more
it's just crazy that we all agree
that with uh we we mostly all agree
what's right and what's wrong and we
kind of stick to it
um because like if julia would be like
look man
i'm gonna give you this deal if you get
fired i'll give you a job
um right but i'm gonna pay i was gonna
pay your company 10 million dollars i'll
give you
just a million of that i'm shocked
one is somebody said this the other day
they go
so how many employees does amazon have
how many points does facebook have how
many players google have
huh i wonder how many foreign spys work
at these companies
a lot it's like it sounds crazy like
foreign spy like what is a movie
it's like no no of course it's not zero
like of course
there are people working for china for
russia for different countries
as foreign agents and there's actually
been like cases of this where guys
basically took the you know like
the machine learning model out on a usb
stick out of google and like basically
went back to russia or like
that's like a thing that has been has
been found um
to be happening in these companies so
one is it's crazy that that's actually
happening that
you know i've probably worked with
somebody who is actually like a foreign
agent which is just like a bizarre
agent on behalf of google i mean how
many times do you think that there's
someone who
is a facebook employee and they're like
hey look
i'm gonna fire you and we're gonna act
like we're not friends anymore
i need you to get a job at snapchat and
i'm gonna
funnel you money and exactly you tell me
everything
everything yeah that totally exists
which is everything that has to happen
we don't talk about it so then so okay
so then
um then i was exactly that so i've had
this experience where i thought
honestly i didn't think anything was
wrong with this but again this is where
maybe my moral compass is a little
screwed up but i was like oh
for example when we got acquired we had
talked to five other companies while we
got acquired
and for each of them they're laying out
their map you know how
what's their strategy how they're going
to win how we fit into that strategy
you know where they're strong where
they're weak what the numbers are so
when we finally got acquired i was i
walked in and i was sort of like guys
congratulations you got me
you got my team you got our code base
but you also
got a little bit of intel no they right
like i talked to they had no interest
i didn't even say anything but i was
like nobody asked me anything
that's insane i and i was like i know i
would if i was in that company's shoes
and i acquired somebody who had talked
through the strategy with the ceo of all
these different companies
i would run like so like what they say
what do they plan like what how do they
view the world well that's not even for
like most people
tell me their secrets it's just like
what were they saying
it's like not it doesn't even seem wrong
to me but the fact that nobody asked me
tells me
huh maybe they do think that would be
wrong to ask maybe my
compass is screwed up what do you think
well this is my whole point which is mo
and
and i just want to say this again
incredibly clear
like i'm not saying i do this or support
it i'm just saying i'm surprised it
doesn't exist but the moral of the story
is most people are actually quite
ethical
and particularly if you're in a room
full of people
they're going to be extra ethical um and
so
i know i'm not surprised that they
didn't do that and i told you but as an
owner
i would have been like hey come here
what uh yeah exactly i wouldn't
especially when i was like at a startup
i act but i wouldn't start if i have
nothing to lose and i have everything
but i wouldn't say like
tell me their numbers i would say like i
would i would just be like what do they
like
what motivates them um are they cool do
they seem like they have their act
together
like these like fluffy questions and
then okay i can say honestly
i totally would have asked for their
numbers i would have been like how big
is it
how much revenue are they doing i i was
guessing you know 500 million is it 500
million
you have to ask those other questions
first you got to like see if they're
going to bite them
you got to see if the person's cool with
it or not yeah you want to make them
uncomfortable
but i am a bit i am surprised um we
uh you and i know someone who was
involved in a lawsuit because
they were hired at one company a large
uh
tech company and previously they had
worked at
the competitor and yeah we could we
could say the names this is public
information all right it was um
anthony popliano he worked at facebook
this is all public this is you can read
the deposition or
i believe it's deposition he didn't tell
us i read i read the deposition like a
nerd and that's how i know yeah and
basically
according to the records that we read he
worked at facebook he decided to work at
snapchat and they said something like
here's a piece of paper write down the
um
the organization chart tell us how it
works and then go and recruit those
people and he
according to the uh deposition said no
that's i'm not a chance
and they fired him snapchat did or or
they like butted heads or something like
that
and uh so yeah i do yeah they putted
heads over that yeah i
i think this stuff happens actually a
fair bit but i'm
actually shocked it doesn't happen more
right i
i thought my only concern in that
situation would just be i don't want to
make my own person my teammate
uncomfortable if they don't feel like
sharing they don't they don't want to
share they feel like that's wrong okay
no problem then
um but if they were down to share i
would 100 be asking all the questions
i'm thinking from my startup brain at a
big company you sort of have more to
lose it's not really worth it
uh you're not like in a like sort of you
know life or death situation of the
company like you don't need the
information
but i really have been surprised like we
will hire people who are like from
youtube or whatever
and they and wherever we're at we're
like hypothesizing like
well you know like how do other
companies handle this blah blah blah
what can we try
i'm like that dude worked there why
don't we just ask that guy like hey dude
what did you guys do
how did it work what was it like is this
retention number good or bad relative to
what you saw like
and nobody asked the question which is
like maybe it's just not in the big
big meeting settings but uh i have been
surprised at that
and i know if you're working like overs
there are other companies that don't
have that same credo i worked for a guy
in indonesia
my first first job i ever had it's kind
of like a summer job
and my dad hooks me up with this guy
he's like oh yeah this guy is known as
the king of coal
in indonesia he owns like all the coal
of indonesia i'm like oh sweet okay
so i'm like i go do the summer job with
this guy what's it was he an american or
an indonesian
he's a chinese guy living in indonesia a
fifth grade dropout
can't speak like any english pretty much
like very broken english
um i he had four women just doing his
email on
giant tv screens in his office because i
don't think he could even type
and uh he was just like or he would like
uh orate like he'd just say out loud
what he wants to reply to every email
and uh and that's how we do his business
and so i like as i get there i'm like oh
cool you're the king of coal like
how'd that happen what'd you do and
basically
what i realized pretty quickly was this
guy's entire business model was
big companies like exxon and bp and
chevron
they all wanted land in indonesia
and the land was owned by the local uh
like
city province they had the rights to it
so they so they had the thing
and um the local guy would just only
like the only way to do business with
this guy was to bribe him
like that's the only thing the guy
wanted was a bribe the local politician
wanted a bribe
if you give him the bribe you can have
the land rights and this chinese
indonesian guy
was a politician no he was the guy he
was the middle man so what he realized
was
um because i was like okay cool we have
this coal what do we do with it he's
like oh we just sell it immediately as
soon as we sign the paper we have the
call
we sell it to exxon and i'm like oh okay
so how does that work he's like well
i bought all this coal for two million
and then we i bought all the coal for
two million
and then we sell it in blocks for 20
million each
i'm like well that's like 400 500
million how are we we're turning 2
million into 500 million
and he's like yeah i'm like well what
that's amazing like
why didn't exxon why don't they just go
in directly by this he's like
like well if they could they would but
they can't so they won't
and basically what he was saying like
those companies did couldn't get their
hands dirty they could not risk
bribing foreign like politicians so what
they did was they let this guy bribe the
follow-up foreign politicians get the
rights and then they would cut a
commercial deal with him
and this guy knew nothing about the coal
like i'd be like oh is this a good asset
bad asset he's like doesn't matter
we get the paper they pay for the paper
like we don't have to do any of the work
we don't have to like extract it mine it
don't have to do anything and now by the
way this guy's a jail like you know
that's the
the end of the story is he's in jail
yeah his name well i i don't wanna
personal risk personal harm
by outing this guy you know we're a
world away but but this guy's kind of a
gangster so i'm not gonna say his name
but
you could you could use what i said in
google basically your dad got you an
internship with a gangster yeah me and
my sister by the way both of us
that's crazy like i remember we were we
were in his office one time
and he had a friend come in and his
friend is like kind of like you know
when it's his friend because it's just
like alcohol like starts pouring women
start showing up at the office like
what's going on here
who are you trying to wine and dine and
it's this one sleazy looking dude
and i was like oh like what's what's
your business he's like i work in
singapore i
help companies on the singapore stock
exchange and literally this was just
straight insider trading so i'm sitting
there
and i'm just hearing this guy be like
yeah these are the three companies you
need to like buy they're like dirt cheap
right now
but they're gonna like they're about to
announce xyz
and they're gonna pop and then they
would just like toast their whiskey and
then they would buy this stock on the
singapore stock exchange or hong kong
stock exchange
and like sure enough the numbers would
go crazy and i was just sitting there
being like wow this is like insanity
that this is
how like loosey-goosey these guys are
with business well what i was gonna say
was
i think that like in uh uh even though
like people
make amazon or whatever to be like evil
uh
you just said no like we would never
even ask this ex-googler about x y and z
and i was going to say
that's like a very american thing i've
have a couple friends who i worked with
who run chinese companies or you know
they're chinese and they're either based
in china
or are now american or the chinese
american now and i have a bunch of
indian friends
um and they're like yeah
we we don't we operate differently than
you our opinion of
the right and wrong way is a lot
different than you and it is
far more unadulterated capitalism of
just
uh what why is copying wrong like
and and they're kind of right right like
why is it wrong but
in any way it is quite interesting yeah
totally uh anyways i don't know how we
got
you want to talk about the first
versions uh we can go back to
yeah what is i saw this website um my
guy
chris chris who's my apprentice right
now for content
he sent this to me and i haven't
actually spent a ton of time on it but
go to firstversions.com
uh check that out and i'm pretty
fascinated with this i think you are too
we both are like
internet archaeologists we like to go
find
the og thing what did i did this blog
post i got like tens of thousands of
views once
uh before i had any audience it just
went viral because it was
what did the first web page look like
for these 10 big companies and this is
kind of like some common to to do
uh like uber's homepage back in the day
snapchats home page back of the day
the first facebook home page uh the
first ebay homepage first amazon
homepage and these things look like
you know so basic and rudimentary and
like really just
it makes you realize like dude you you
need to launch and there's that quote if
you're not embarrassed by v1 of your
product you launch too late and
all these companies definitely like fall
into that category so i thought
firstversion.com was a cool little like
archive of stuff like this i think this
is so cool so i actually just sent you a
link
to an article that i wrote i think i
wrote this in 16 2016
years ago uh 15 october 15.
and i you could
it probably doesn't even work entirely
but anyway i what i love to do and i've
always loved doing this
is i use there's a few different
websites web archives the easiest
and what i like to do is i will
[Music]
get a google doc in a spreadsheet and
i'll
map out the the whole journey of a
company so i'll look at where when
airbnb started and then i'll read
all about them of like all right here's
when they announced they had this many
users here were there here's where they
announced this much funding
here's where they said they had up their
first 50 employees and then from 50 they
actually went to a thousand in only two
years
and then i'll take screenshots of their
website
and in doing that you can actually see
what like how the
the evolution so progression yeah and
i'm just starting i'm just making this
up with airbnb but it could be like
it started as air betting breakfast and
it was about renting cots
inside of a living room and then oh wow
they actually changed their
their positioning to travel like a local
and they started um
taking higher end pictures i don't know
what it is but uh
and when they started actually taking
higher end pictures that was actually
right when they right before they raised
their 100 million dollar funding
and so anyway you can actually track the
progression really nicely by doing this
and i love doing that i love it and so
you can actually see
oh uber ubercab.com they were only black
car services
oh when they raised all this money they
actually got rid of the black car the
black car became secondary so actually
the black card didn't work
uh so they switched to this you know
what i mean so it's kind of cool yeah
you can totally reverse engineer a lot
of the stuff so some of the tools we use
to do this
the wayback machine which is the
internet archive so uh just google
wayback machine
that lets you put in any domain name and
you go back in time and they took
screenshots
of what the website looked like on june
12 20
2010 and then that you can go back you
can see uber's what did who uber's
homepage looked like back then how were
they describing themselves
another one i do is techcrunch i go to
techcrunch i search for a company's name
and then i reverse sort it
by the earliest mention of it so like
you can go twitter you can see the very
first article
is you know mike arrington being like
you know the buzz at the party this week
uh was about twitter spelled without the
you know without the vowels basically
it's like
the short messaging service it was kind
of fun you do do this but you know
who cares you know people are just
tweeting about there they're just
tweeting about their breakfast and it
was all through sms like
you could kind of see what was going on
then so i like that one that's that's a
useful one
another one i'll do is i'll go on
twitter and you can twitter advanced
search so you can type in anyone's name
and you could do things like uh twitter
doesn't make this obvious how to do it
there's like a format of how you write
these in but you write like
at the sam par before
2011 and then you say minimum
300 likes and i can kind of go see your
most popular post at that point in time
what were you talking about what was
working for you what wasn't
so i've done this with a whole bunch of
people and i kind of like i really am a
big
reverse engineer type of guy it's not
that you can copy it
but it's just data points it's a way to
fast-forward experience
because experience the hard way is slow
it takes like decades to get good at
things and to learn and to like
figure out what's normal what's not
what's fast what's slow what's good
what's bad
and a better way to do it is to like
download a whole bunch of data points
quickly
and it's not perfect experience but it's
better than being blind and just kind of
like
going off only your personal experience
so there's some ways i would actually go
as far to say you can copy it
um you you can you actually can copy a
lot of stuff and i think you should
sometimes so
for example this first by the way
firstversions.com
this is a wonderful website this is such
a good website
uh i uh this is so cool um
i wish they don't by the way what they
do is not just
internet like what like what we're
talking about is home pages because
that's like kind of our niche but
they'll be like
this is the yeah this is the first
version of tom and jerry like the very
first pilot and like last night i don't
know why
for a reason before i went to bed i was
watching the very first
pilot episode of curb your enthusiasm
before it was even a show
and i was i just love seeing that og og
the first pilot of always sunny in
philadelphia where they're using the
handheld camera
like i like seeing that because it just
as somebody who
is frequently starting things it's
important to go see that your favorite
things started with very
humble simple kind of shitty beginnings
and
uh and then you know you sort of can see
how much better they got over time
this is so good uh i love this uh i'm
gonna
link you some uh link something to you
so in 2013
i created this thing i called uh the ceo
doc it was a stupid name
but uh i i sent it to you and you can
actually see that
it's so funny that you do this because i
mean we're it's it's so funny that we're
similar and we've been doing this for
years
so i created oh wait is it not working
um i created this document
where i would take i think i had a list
of 500 people
and i would make timelines for each of
their lives and i would say
started their it was broken into
apprenticeships first hit
and then the self-actualization mode so
for example
uh jack dorsey started apprenticeship at
age 22 from 22 to 28 he basically was
like this poor
nobody who worked as a dispatch service
for taxi cab
company 28 to 31 started twitter at 28
uh it actually became a pretty big hit
really soon at
uh 29 and so i have timelines and i have
average ages
a average age for each person and so um
i love doing that stuff and it works so
good uh
for for just seeing like what's possible
um
right so we're actually quite similar uh
i've been doing this as well for a while
yeah it's great to nerd out about this
kind of stuff um okay so first versions
is cool
i have another kind of cool thing okay
here's a
here's an idea i would say this is not a
business it's probably a very bad idea
maybe this is something that
this is you reminded me of it because
this thing that we're doing
is uh like the thing we're talking about
is extremely nerdy and
probably most people don't don't do what
we're describing like kind of like go
back and
map out the evolution of companies or
people or whatever it is
so similarly i i want a tool that i'm
calling business pocket
so pocket is this chrome extension it's
this app or service where you like
if you see an article you like but you
don't have time to read it you just hit
pocket and it's like you put it in your
pocket for later do you think
i think it used to be called read it
later you think pocket is going well i
bet you it's going pretty badly i bet
you that'd be a cool company to buy
yeah i don't think it's going well it
got really big and it raised a bunch of
money and then like
it's just been around for so long
without like an exit that
you wonder did it just get like become
obsolete somehow
um along the way but anyways it was just
a way to save articles
now i actually want something what i'll
call business pocket so i have this
bookmark thing in my chrome that's
called
companies to watch it's based like any
time i stumble across a company i find
it interesting i've been doing
it it's like this thing is like 10 years
old now i find an interesting company
and before it used to be i want to see
if this will be successful
or maybe i should if i was an investor i
would invest in this so i want to like
flag this and then i'll come back later
in three years and i'll see how it
turned out
whether i would have made money or lost
money on this thing and so i've just
been collecting this for a long time now
in reality i hit i bookmark it and then
i like never go back and go recheck
those because who's got the time
but um i would love a service that's
almost like a programmatic newsletter
where i can just flag either people or
companies that i say i want to keep a
watch
i want to keep watch on this company or
this this this individual
and um like the ceo or maybe this
company the startup
and then i wanted to like basically take
the 10 that i've flagged
and send me anytime there's interesting
news about them with some filter like
you know
they raise new funding they got a new
job they they
they announced this thing they're on tv
whatever and um
and you know my 12 that i'm tracking
might be different than the 12 that
you're tracking
but like we might have three that are
the same and so this company that's
underneath that would just need to set
up like a
kind of like a programmatic way to like
watch for the news around certain names
and then turn it into an automated
newsletter that was kind of just like a
random idea
i don't think it's a business but i
think it would be i disagree i think
it's a business when we were
getting ready to decide if we wanted to
launch trends or watch
launch something new i wrote a landing
page for this product
i forget what i called it but something
involving the word spy
and i put like the headline was like
we're your secret spy
spies that track your competitors and
tell you everything that they do so you
know
and we deliver to you via email and
uh i think this actually could have
worked wonderfully and the reason i came
up with this idea
was i had a friend who worked at rocket
internet rocket internet
google it it's a it's a guy it's three
brothers uh
named ali alex and something else
samware brothers
and they started this thing called
rocket internet and basically
the way it works right now it's a large
publicly traded company
they had this like guy named he was like
the chief scientist
and what they would do is they would
research fast growing companies in
america and they would clone them
and they would deploy that company in
africa in
asia different parts of europe things
like that
brazil and so they cloned uber but in
mexico
they cloned pinterest but for germany
they cloned
zappos but for germany they did um
amazon for time they owned like the
amazon for brazil i think
yeah and they also owned the amazon for
thailand and they would pick a variety
of companies they would do
like the wayfarer for nigeria or
something like that
and they had this guy who's who was
called the chief scientist
and all the clones of the amazon
of this country that country that
country there'd probably be like eight
clones
and he would send an email every day
this is the story i heard i don't know
if it's true he would send an email
every day and it'd be like
hey everyone amazon uh actually just
moved on their homepage
they moved the clothing from uh eight
pic or a hundred pixels to the left
uh it probably means that clothing is a
little bit more popular now than
furniture
so all right make sure you move your
clothing thing or hey they uh they
changed their color
of this button from this yellow to this
orange go ahead and do that
and i thought that's pretty awesome i
would love to have that i would love
to track my competitors because i would
do research on my competitors i would
say oh which ads are they using
oh i wonder why they're using this ad
maybe maybe they're using this ad for
this one this reason that reason and
that reason i'm gonna go and copy it and
i would use
a variety of similar web uh facebook ad
archive
uh aha refs and a few other things and i
would i would
just i would like oh here's where
they're succeeding and here's why
they're succeeding
i may copy them i may not copy them and
i just i just know what's working
and i think that that 100 could be a
service that you pay a hundred grand a
year for
and you get and you and they'll tell you
the five nearest competitors and every
month you meet with their team and you
say
all right your competitors they're doing
this they're doing that they're doing
this
here's what's working here's what's not
working right here's a higher pi
hypothesis
hypothesis as to what what all this
means
and i think actually you could charge a
six-figure annual contract
for all of it and i think it would be a
really cool company
right yeah i told you about my friend
who i i nudged in this direction to do
this for for e-commerce
uh i'll give him another shout out here
he said he got a bunch of sales last
time i mentioned it so i'll do it again
shopify sales data.com basically a way
to track your competitors
um who and how much they're selling and
what new ads they're running and stuff
like that
and um just in the niche of e-commerce
and it's
you know i don't know 100 bucks a month
or something like that and um i paid for
it i'm like this is a great
uh you know it's a valuable service and
so you could do it in a niche or you
could do it you know more broadly but uh
but yeah i think that's cool um let's
give you a different topic you want to
do one more
did you want to do the pets thing you've
had that here for two weeks
um so this is actually like a really
what i thought was a really random idea
and then i saw an ad i saw a commercial
for it on tv yesterday
and it's like totally a thing so it's
just going to sound stupid because it
was like
a stupid basically i was like uh
kids love having pets pets are like a
pain in the ass maintenance wise
and your kid wants it but they're not
going to maintain it i was thinking
about like that's why people get fish
because it's kind of like self-contained
in this little tank and you don't have
to do anything most the time
just feed it a fish die all the time
it's really sad for the kid
and so i was like why is there not just
like ai pets why aren't they just like
robo pets
um for kids and i was like oh a fish
would work because
it just needs to swim around sort of
aimlessly you don't touch it so even if
it was mechanical
it wouldn't feel cold like a mechanical
dog i don't think will feel great
but um dude that is you know mechanical
fish you you hit home runs
this is such a dud this is such a dud
you you're a home run hitter today's a
strikeout this is a stupid
stupid idea you are well i saw the
commercial before it was called robo
fish yesterday and i was like oh this
exists no way
oh my gosh so i'm going to go check
everybody see if you can see does
robo i think it's called robo fish i saw
the commercial
tell me to do 100 million dollars a year
and prove that this is not a dud
so anyways that was one and then there's
a related one which is
there's a medical thing that's going on
for you know like pets are sometimes
labeled as like kind of like a
emotional support dog or whatever it's
like anti-anxiety that sort of thing you
know that's total [__] too right
well i know most people use it for
[__] i don't know if there's any
medical like
uh like there must be some like cases
where it helps or something like that no
i agree
that in some cases it is true but um
a lot of like like people like oh
they're certified and emotional like
there's not like a certification process
yeah there's no yeah exactly this dog
did not get trained um
but but anyways i saw this company that
was doing this with for for people with
dementia and alzheimer's
they were giving them this weighted it's
the equivalent of a weighted blanket but
it's a pet
so it's a pet that sits in your lap it's
heavy and like a weighted blanket
but it feels like a pet and it moves
like a pet now if you're like
totally if you're just like an adult
who's has no health conditions you'll be
like oh this is like clearly a robot
this blink is like not really fully
natural and you know this dog's
obviously not running anywhere it's not
a real pet
but to somebody with you know dementia
or alzheimer's they found that this like
is extremely comforting to them
now they're really expensive right now
uh they're like thousands of dollars for
this like really kind of like realistic
feeling thing what's it called but
um but they're gonna bring the price
down i don't know i met this guy who um
through my wife she she was consulting
for this company that was doing it
and she was showing me the videos and
stuff like that about this thing so i
thought that was kind of cool too
but i think that we will see more and
more either
genetically engineered pets or just
straight up kind of like
mechanical ai pets because if you can
get
sixty percent of the benefits with zero
percent of the work and maintenance i
think there's a whole class of people
who
take that trade um that today just don't
own pets because it's just too much cost
and too much work
so man i called your thing totally
stupid
i think for the average oh yeah hold on
receipts
come in and tell sam tell sam about the
robo face i mean i don't know if this is
what you were talking about but this
company in 2012 they sold 15 million of
these at eight bucks a piece in their
first year
well first year that's right all right i
i'm both i kind of take back and i don't
take that
so you're wrong in that you're saying
like oh pets are so annoying just give
them a robot pet
like yeah i think that's actually silly
i don't doubt that people buy a robo
fish i think that's just like
a cute little widget that's fun to have
but
dude you were the one who was like oh
these ai girlfriends are great
uh it's the same idea it's the same
premise okay well look i'm open-minded
enough to like uh
challenge my views but i you started
talking about this alzheimer's thing and
that's actually quite interesting i just
googled it i wanted to see which ads
come up i like because like so i googled
this thing i'm
i it's kind of i don't really like
looking at this i feel a little sleazy
but there's this oh i actually don't
like the name there's a name
called i just sent it to the alls all
store
so alz store and it stands for the
alzheimer's store
and they call it the all store and they
sell
um like these live strong bands that
have your name on it so if you can
when you forget your name remember and
they actually have a robotic
therapy dog and this website
actually looks like it's like a
entrepreneur who's just looking for a
money-making niche
which a little weird with with this type
of thing
but people seem to love it it's a whole
store
dedicated to alzheimer's products i have
zero idea if this is like actually what
alzheimer's patients love and need but
this is incredibly fascinating
and i'm looking at their similar web
traffic no i actually think this is
legit they have videos of them of the
founder talking on like the today's show
about selling all types of products for
alzheimer's stuff
and i'm looking at their uh similar web
traffic and it's incredibly
popular what a fascinating business all
about alzheimer's yeah i know this is a
legit
uh company i'm looking at the about page
this they have a good background story
of the
the father has alzheimer's so now they
create all these products
it looks pretty interesting can you
believe that this exists the all store
right
that's wild i had no idea um but makes
sense i guess uh i guess that does make
sense
i have one more can i do last two
minutes billy of the week story
um the second billy of the week story i
learned this i tweeted this thing
i tweeted this out and it kind of this
kind of blew my mind okay so
i was doing some you know shoe dog is
like super popular about the founding
story of nike yeah you did one on
adidas i did one on adidas and as i was
like
okay nike great uh what's the story with
adidas where did that come from
and so i just started googling for a
second and i didn't go
so in-depth but okay here is the
60-second version of adidas so
fir uh tell me if you knew these things
just give me a yay or an a if you knew
it or not so
adidas when you were a kid did you not
hear that this stood for all day i dream
about sports yeah
soccer all day i dream about soccer
soccer yeah yeah that's right
not true uh basically you know the guy's
name was adolf dossler who started it
and he went by
adi dossler dude uh so it's just adidas
i was in germany one time and someone a
german was like do you like adidas i'm
like i don't know what that is
like a german brand they're like oh no
it's adidas you don't know adidas goes
no i've never heard of it and they
started laughing at me
that's adidas i guess yeah right
i'm sure you corrected him i was about
his own hometown oh you've been taking
this yeah i know
that's not i don't know adidas
so okay so the story is kind of crazy so
uh two brothers
basically dad owns a leather shoe
factory the two sons are like okay shoes
are cool but
we want to do sports shoes not these
like leather shoes and so they spin out
and they create
the dossler brothers shoe factory and
what they do is they're like we're gonna
you know adi you're gonna design the
shoes and
uh rudy you're gonna sell the shoes you
do sales and marketing two brothers
they do that right uh it's like a
ten-year grind
you know building this thing up they're
growing but they're growing slowly and
then finally 1936 the olympics come to
germany
and um they are a whole bunch of the
athletes from germany are wearing adidas
but they also get a little bit you know
they go and they hustle and they get
their adidas shoes in the hands of some
non-german athletes also
one of whom is jesse owens jesse owens
goes on
to win i think four gold medals at those
olympics and so jesse
this is a black guy who basically wins
gold and beats the germans
in front of hitler who's like promoting
white supremacy at the time and so it's
a
you know a big deal for for that victory
um at the time he's wearing adidas
and this is kind of considered the first
time that
an entrepreneur used sports to promote
their products or their businesses and
he kept doing this right like you see
photos of ollie versus frasier they're
both wearing adidas because
he was like hell-bent on getting adidas
into the hands of all the iconic
athletes that they could
which nike went and took that strategy
and did even better with that strategy
over time
um and so they you know business is
going great
that you know after that olympics thing
where they get all this exposure
next three years they sell like i don't
know 600 000 pairs of shoes
business is great uh you know 1940 hits
and world war world war ii starts and
the factory just gets seized by the
german military they're like this is now
a war factory we need to produce
war goods here no more shoes and hey you
two brothers
join the army so they they get enrolled
in the army so the business just goes on
break
adidas just like goes out of business
for the whole world war
okay world war ii ends the brothers come
back
uh you know andy's like all right he
gets 50 people together he's like we're
restarting the factory we're going to do
this again
and somewhere along the way the two
brothers break up so i didn't know this
part
yeah i know that the other brother goes
on to start puma yeah and so one brother
starts adidas the other brother starts
puma which i just thought was like you
know the most baller [__] you knew that
already
yeah i know that they got an argument
well known yeah
uh well i don't know but i mean you're
talking to me uh
i think that uh yeah they got into an
argument one of them started puma
for some reason i thought that he he
like did he move to africa and start
puma
is there any part of that no i think he
like literally moved across the river
and like started a competing factory
within like earshot
that's that's the way i read it maybe i
read that wrong yeah i knew and
and the two brothers because they got
into a disagreement on how to do oh
uh bray said reebok started in africa so
i guess i'm getting confused
but uh yeah yeah i knew that so they
they restart the factory after the war
and now they're using all the war like
leftover war materials in the shoes like
rubber for the souls
and like certain design like the look of
camouflage and different things like
that they come up with the three stripe
logo
and so anyways business does good and
then like there's this crazy run
of death so the puma brother dies four
years later
the adi dies you know from adidas he
dies his wife takes over
she dies six years later the sun takes
over he dies three years later so this
is like this
run of early deaths it's like you know
the defensive against the dark arts
position nobody can like
hold this thing and so that finally now
the two daughters have owned the thing
they sell it for pennies on the dollar
because adidas has just been declining
for years now at this point
you know they didn't have the right
people running it i guess and so they
sell it for 500 million dollars
um uh you know to this french guy french
guy tries to turn around he can't do it
it's on the verge of bankruptcy and then
they sell it to this guy this is the
actually the billy of the week
uh it's this guy dreyfus and um i think
his name is robert dreyfuss oh
do you know who you know who this
person's related to
right no uh his dad was rich but
i don't know why he's rich uh i believe
it's elaine from seidenfelp that's her
uh uh julia dreyfuss yes i believe uh
i believe that's her grandpa
wow okay that's crazy so this guy grows
up kind of rich
goes to like harvard or whatever uh buys
this thing
his tagline i love it he goes i'm a
gambler
and i like turnarounds that was kind of
like his business philosophy so he takes
a gamble
takes the lead role at adidas and he
basically is like all right we're doing
three things we're moving the factory to
asia
we're cutting the payroll we're cutting
jobs cutting two-thirds of the jobs in
this company so we can get profitable
and lastly we're gonna take that money
we were spending on people and we're
gonna spend a [__] ton of it on
marketing
and you know they were like wow you know
you took it from the brink of bankruptcy
three percent market share
and it came roaring back and became the
number two brand how'd you do it you
know you must be a genius and he goes
you know he was in time magazine the
quote is it didn't take a genius you
just had to look at what nike and reebok
were doing
and do that he goes it was just easier
for somebody outside the company to see
what was obvious
than somebody inside the company who had
all this baggage and they couldn't do it
and uh you know so he he turns it around
retires a billionaire you know
in his 50s i think and uh and that is
you know the crazy story of adidas
today i thought that was wild i had no
idea so there's two takeaways
of this for me um the first is
a question that i should start asking
myself and and you don't actually need
to
follow through but how would a pe firm
run your company
i actually think that's a great question
to ask yourself which is what would a pe
firm do
if they were if they owned this right
now and that's kind of an interesting
way to get ideas because
you kind of say to yourself oh man i'm
being such a punk like
i could be so much better the second
thing and and the opposite
and the opposite would be what would you
know larry page
do groups of google's you know ceo and
founder or doc um
yeah like but yeah they took this small
thing and they just kept expanding it
like no we need to do google x we need
to do moonshot projects self-driving
cars
you know satellites into the sky giving
people internet like
they had like unbridled you know
ambition and were like
what if you just like blew the top off
this thing in ambition and then the
other one is
the pe the ruthless operator way what
would they do i think both are valuable
questions for your business and the
second thing
and this is actually something that i've
been thinking a lot about because i've
been thinking about louis vuitton
uh not that i don't even own one louis
vuitton thing i'm never gonna own all
the louis vuitton thing
but it's pretty fascinating that i in my
head i stereotyped
fashion brands it's just like trendy and
and they they're gonna come and go like
uh but in reality it i would bet
that some of these fashion brands like
adidas puma louis vuitton
they're actually some of the longest
lasting companies i imagine i could
think of
and that's pretty fascinating that a
brand like adidas
that went through near bankruptcy went
through multiple owners
is still relevant in kicks ass and
that's actually pretty cool to create
something that can last that long
and uh right it's kind of cool i think
that's actually inspiring
that something uh with withstood all
that
nonsense like it succeeded in spite of
especially in fashion
especially in fashion where everybody
wants to do it and fashion like
literally
is kind of like in and out of fashion
it's like a fad type of uh
type of business where things go in and
out of style so quickly so just to last
there is pretty impressive
what i'm saying is there's some stuff
that it just it has lasted for
many many decades so uh louis vuitton
luggage
i i imagine existed at the turn of the
century in the 1900s
same with um the uh um right now i'm
wearing nike cortez
i just looked at the uh the website that
we were talking about earlier first
versions
and the first version of nike was the
nike cortez and i'm still wearing the
same damn model
and it's kind of interesting and
inspiring to create something that can
last
50 100 200 years and uh that's kind of a
cool part that's how i feel about like
altoids or coca-cola
yeah i guess you could do it i mean you
can do it a lot more than fashion but
there are a bunch of fashion brands that
have done it successfully and i think
that's pretty damn cool you know like uh
rolex or tiffany's diamonds or something
like that
it's kind of neat
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in
never looking back